hi good morning thanks so much for being
here I heard you had a fun night last
night so thanks for getting up and for
having me it's really great to be here
and get get to talk to you so basically
the starting point of my work has always
been around studying social systems
computationally and of course society
nothing new that people have been
connected via some kind of small network
for as long as humans have been around
but what's really changed recently it's
just the amount of data we have about
these interactions and how this data is
being used in the algorithms that
facilitate this communication and these
interactions between people between
people and companies between companies
themselves and what is going on is
really an interplay it's not just the
mechanism of communication that has
changed what's happened is that these
algorithms especially with all this data
that that is now available they are
learning from people and adopting their
behavior changing how how they work
based on what information they have
about people and for me the most
interesting part is that the flip side
is also true based on what the
algorithmic content is being shown to
you or displayed to us our behavior is
also changing both individually and
collectively as a society and it's
really this interplay which is the focus
of a lot of my work and very recently
looking at how this loop that forms can
sometimes exacerbate societal biases
that already exists and seeing ways that
we can figure out how to break this
cycle or what I would make our
optimization tools can we use that allow
us to still facilitate all the fantastic
things that technology has done without
propagating or making all these societal
problems any worse so just to give a
couple of examples of where these
problems have have shown
up and all of these have received a some
amount of media attention and there's a
lot of kind of articles out there if you
if you want to learn more yeah but one
recent study brought to light by a
public in the US was about the use of
algorithmic decision-making in court
cases so judges in various states in the
US have access to an algorithm which
predicts for criminal or potential
criminals standing in front of them what
is the likelihood that they will
recommit a crime and this information
this algorithmic prediction is being
used to decide who gets bail for example
or who gets released on parole so
they're making these very big
life-changing decisions for individuals
and various studies have shown that the
algorithms that do this have biases they
if depending on the person's profile
their ethnicity and their background
they will change the prediction so this
one a very clear example where an
algorithm has basically picked up some
of these biases that are in society due
to context due to history and then are
using them to predict outcomes and I can
have very negative consequences to
individuals another another recent
example called the search engine
manipulation effect has shown that based
on the order in which you see articles
news articles about candidates not even
the content just change the order in
which you're presented with articles by
a search engine that can change your
political preference so that can
potentially affect your vote in an
election and this was done in a few
different countries and the US Australia
and India as well showing how people can
be influenced again just by the
presentation order in a way that is
strong enough to change their vote
another example kind of moving to the
online space so this is just a
screenshot of the Wall Street Journal
read feed blue feed if you haven't seen
it it's a fun little tool to play around
with what they do is they show you for a
variety of topics this is a president
Truong topic what your news
would look like on facebook if you're
very liberal versus if you're very
conservative so you can just scroll
through this and you see that it's not
just the leaning of the coverage that
changes the content is actually
completely different so that even the
information that we see can be
completely different from what our
neighbor sees and depending on what
these algorithms have learned about our
personal ideas or preferences and so
this type of thing has led to completely
polarized online spaces a couple more
examples if you look at Google Images so
again this is a recent study out of the
University of Washington if you search
for various professions on Google Images
what is shown is actually a skewed
gender representation of what is there
in reality so this is an example of an
algorithm that's actually changing in
some sense the ground truth so if you
look at this is CEOs in the US it's
something like twenty seven percent of
CEOs are women in Europe it's a little
bit higher and close to thirty percent
and if you but if you look at the top
Google Image searches it's something
like eleven percent and this is true of
every profession they look at whatever
the gender ratio actually is the results
skewed it more so again it's an example
of an algorithm kind of learning some
bias or some disproportion in the real
world and accelerating it and what they
showed in this study as well is that
again this affects our perceptions so if
you go and you have seen these results
that affects your own idea of what the
gender balances in these professions and
as a last example there's also a lot of
studies on online advertising and how
these in the effort to personalize and
target and show you ads that you're
interested in it can also actually
exacerbate biases or things like ads for
high paying jobs are far less likely to
be shown to women than they are to men
so here in this case you're just
actually explicitly decreasing the
opportunity for a lot of women
because of again this this thing that
algorithm has learned it has learned
that on average men make more money than
women and therefore it thinks that this
slight difference means that this that
men are more likely to click on this ad
and this gets turned into something that
I can then skew skew what happens down
the line so overall these all of these
examples and there's many more have come
up recently as ways in which algorithms
can basically increase discrimination
you can manipulate elections there are
polarizing opinions and the question is
really what can we do about this as
technologists what can we do and that's
really what leads me to this question of
questions of fairness or questions of
diversity and to start breaking down the
problem you have to think about where
why is this happening where where is
this arising you can kind of think of
this is breaking down in two different
places so of course there's a real world
which as we said it comes with its
history and its context and its own
inherent biases and what that means is
of course that whenever we collected
that data often is biased even if we had
a perfect world in that data collection
bias in that data collection process we
can end up biasing data so there's the
first step where we start encoding this
these biases in the data itself then of
course we have some algorithm that is
learning from this data and here the
important point to understand is that
these algorithms can also introduce bias
so it's not just that they're kind of
taking biased data and learning from it
but they can actually make that skewers
or even if you give them perfect data
they themselves can can result in in
bias outcomes and that's because of the
optimization effectively that we put on
top of it so when we're building an
algorithm we have a purpose right we're
not doing it for this thing I'm doing it
would have some goal in mind and that
goal it might be a clear-cut technical
goal but in its interaction with the
world can actually end up skewing things
and what happens is one
you have these algorithmic biases as I
mentioned in these examples this can
feed back into the real world they can
change our perceptions you can change
outcomes and it's this kind of vicious
cycle that we want to break so to give
you the cartoon version of what I mean
here if we have say two populations four
people say we're a bank we want to
decide who to give a loan to we have
these people who have applied on these
axis now the distributions again in this
cartoon version are a little bit
different because the real world is a
little bit different so that's this
pre-existing bias no technical bias
might arise by coming up by introducing
something very simple say I just say the
x-axis is income and I just want a
simple income cut off alright that's a
perfectly reasonable algorithm one could
have of course you can do much fancier
things but in conjunction in this case
with the pre-existing bias in the data
what happens is if I just give everyone
to the right of this cutoff line alone
now the percentage of men versus women
in this cartoon example I have received
that low interest loan is is higher
right and this can feel bad because of
course if you get that loan you have
higher earning potential if you don't
get that loan then you have to maybe
take a high interest loan maybe you
don't get to do what you want to do and
this this is what feeds back into the
real world so what is the high level
goal here
there's many there's not many people
studying studying these problems and
which is really exciting the type of
things that I do primarily are around
detecting the bias a lot and focus on
developing the solutions actually
looking at the algorithms what can we do
to break this cycle in that way and then
I also do a lot of work talking to
companies or talking to policymakers
trying to see where we can get where we
can get these algorithms used but I
think really and one of the great things
about being here and talking to all of
you is that I think this is something
that is really a message that that needs
to be kind of embraced more more widely
by people who are writing code who are
developing software who are doing
research and data science or looking at
all these things because it's something
that we really have to I think keep in
mind
as a culture as a profession it's not
something that we can ignore because
just focusing on the technical side we
will be creating bias algorithms whether
we want to or not it's something very
important for us to to really think
about as we move as we move forward now
okay I've been saying bias and fairness
kind of interchangeably without really
defining it partly there's this is
because of many different ways of
thinking about what that means very
concretely and really these ways can be
broken down into two two camps
so one camp is thinks of things as
individual fairness so individual
fairness means is that if two
individuals are identical except for
what we call sensitive attributes so
their gender their ethnicity their
sexual orientation etc so if two
individuals are identical except for
these specific kind of protected
attributes then the algorithm should
treat them exactly the same that's what
it means to be individually fair now
there's another camp that talks about
booth fairness and what group fairness
means is that when we have collections
of people say broken down by gender or
broken down by ethnicity when we have a
group each group as a whole should be
treated the same as other groups so both
of these kind of high-level definitions
make sense and they both seem like
worthwhile things for our algorithms to
have the problem is that the two
concepts are largely incompatible
there's some very strong and possibility
results that say that unless your
populations have kind of very specific
distributions you're not going to be
able to satisfy both and again I'll give
you just a very simple cartoon example
of why this happens so you have have two
two populations you have some red
population and some blue population that
are distributed slightly differently now
if you want to be individually fair
whatever you decide for these groups
cannot take into account the
you're not take into account red or blue
so again if we kind of think of some
simple cutoff or we can choose any any
process I can't take red and blue into
account or tailor it to either one
otherwise it wouldn't be individually
fair so if I say okay everyone above
this cutoff line gets my loan now you
have this problem that I showed before
right we have far more blue people than
red people here if you say okay that's I
don't think that's fair I want to be
blue fair I want the same percent of
blue and red people well then by
necessity you have to have different
part of values for the two right you're
not going to be able to be both
individually fair and fair now what is
the right definition I don't know and
this is kind of one of the key questions
or the first key question that you
should think about whenever you're
trying to design something for him for
an application what is the right notion
of fairness in this particular context
and it will look completely dependent I
mean I don't have a straightforward
answer for you and this is part of the
the fun but also the challenge of
thinking about these kind of problems
right in some context maybe when we're
dealing with with humans we really have
to be individually fair and many of the
online contacts I find that group
fairness often works well because they
were talking about selecting content as
opposed to selecting individuals so I
don't find so many scenarios in which
it's problematic to have different
treatments for different pieces of
content so largely in a lot of the
things I've done and focus on group
fairness and to tell you a little bit a
little bit more precisely what that
might look like we can think of having
some some collection of content and
there is going to be some kind of
selected set so this is a set of content
that I'm going to display on on Facebook
news or I'm going to as a set of images
that I'm going to display to you and
what happens is this content you can
think of it as being broken down into
groups the group structure can be
arbitrary but for simplicity let's say
it's just a partition and so we have
Group one through
Group G and they just partition the
space into these different groups and
what these definitions pull down to is
basically they're a function of the
percentage of items from each group that
end up getting selected into this set of
s should we let PIB that percentage now
again there's kind of different notions
of what it means to be fair but roughly
to be group fair you want that
percentage to be the same or roughly the
same for all different groups that's
what it means to be fair now within that
there's many different ways of doing
that of measuring how close is close
enough right or what is the right metric
or should I look at the percentage
groups or how you split up these groups
or things like that but for all these
kind of very different notions the good
news is that there's more and more kind
of fast fair algorithms that are being
developed so there's more and more
available algorithms that we can use and
of course there's different approaches
of doing this but when I started kind of
working in this area I still found this
a little bit unsatisfying that okay fine
I have to there's a kind of impossible
result that means I have to focus on
either individual fairness or group
fairness for a particular application
that's fine but within group fairness
there's all these different ways of
measuring fairness and what is the right
way again seems very context dependent
and finding a new algorithm for each
application and each definition just
seemed overwhelming and it really seemed
like we would end up in this kind of
weird state where it's not clear what
fairness is who is deciding what
finances and who's deciding which are
the right algorithms to develop so the
type of work that I've been doing along
with my my colleagues is trying to kind
of go up a level and think of a more
general framework for group constraints
so instead of giving a fixed definition
and saying this is what it means to be
fair the type of algorithms that we have
were that we're developing let you take
in as input some constraints on these
probabilities so now for every P I you
can give me an upper and lower bound
that says okay I need this P I to be
with
some certain range and you give a
different burn around if you like for
each different people now what this lets
you do is that if you have a certain
definition of friends that you need for
your particular application now it boils
down to what is almost always a much
simpler problem of translating your
definition into the right upper and
lower bound constraints so that you can
usually do very very easily so now for
almost any type of fairness definition
that you have once you you just have to
worry about translating to the
constraints and we have algorithms that
can help you achieve the people that you
want now what is nice about these
constraints is that okay as I said they
can satisfy all these different furnace
metrics but they're also very simple
right these are convex constraints not
even a difficult convex body they're
just very simple box-like constraints
and what that's going to let us do it's
also developed a lot of fast algorithms
because as long as soon as we want to do
this at scale it we really need
something fast so let me give you two
examples of where we've done this one
example is personalization or
personalized content so again the
cartoon version of this is of course we
have a whole bunch of content let's say
there's two types of content freedom
drill and our algorithm is going to
select from this content to show on your
feed so on your Facebook feed newsfeed
whatever it might be
now of course these personalized
algorithms they're constantly learning
about you right so they're seeing what
you like or you don't like what you read
what you click on what you hover over
and all this information is being fed
back and the more and more the algorithm
learns about you and the more and more
personalized if he becomes so again the
cartoon version is that you were just
thinking of each person as some point in
some high dimensional space and
depending on what they like in the speed
that image of this person or that
have a sensation of this person is
moving and of course what deletes is to
this red feed blue feed phenomenon is
that as we learn we just allow you to
move more and more into the corners of
this space right so eventually what
we're seeing are completely different
types of content so what is what are
these constraints in this cartoon
version it's basically just a little
sense so we're not letting you just
reach these extremes so again this is
something very simple that for most
algorithms it's basically a very easy
cutoff point or throttle that you can
add on to make sure that you don't over
personalize to be a bit more concrete
one of the ways in which personalization
can be done is via these multi-armed
bandit type of problems where we have
these key arms which correspond to your
types of content and basically what this
and this algorithm is doing is
maintaining a probability distribution
this is just kind of this point in this
space as to what it thinks that you like
right and every time of course it has to
select some content to show you and then
it receives what is in this language
called the reward which is how much you
like that right did you like until you
read it that you just scroll past it and
what these algorithms do is try to
figure out what is the ideal arm what is
your perfect type of content right there
is your favorite type of content and
what it does is it tries to learn this
and how well it learns as measured by
reflect but it tries to learn this and
then once it learns this it'll basically
just always show you that type of
content and that's again what leads us
to this type of polarization now what
these algorithms are trading off is
what's called a balance between
exploration and exploitation exploration
means kind of testing different things
out in case there's something else that
you like that we missed out on and
exploitation is actually just showing
you what you like a lot right so again
to give some cartoon version if you have
all these all these different content
here represented by people that you're
trying to select okay each time step I
choose something if you like it then I'm
going to end up putting more probability
mass
in fact I put almost all the probability
mass on there this is a simple algorithm
but many many multi unbranded
algorithms and roughly think of this way
so with the with most of probability
mass I just put it on the best option so
far and then with a small probability
mass I put it on everyone else and as I
keep selecting content I keep changing
who I think is better what the best
option is but overall it always ends up
like this
alright so eventually what happens over
time is that you converge to something
and now it's not just that that type of
content with that one specific one
specific type of content gets most of
the probability mass so what is the
solution basically again it's just a
small tree from this algorithm so what
these constraints mean in the setting is
that the probability mass on any
particular group or type of content has
to be constrained within these upper and
lower bounds that we that we have
defined or can take as input so say okay
I can only put kind of between 5 and 10
of these blocks of probability mass in
there or whatever it is that your
constraints are going to be and now the
goal has changed right instead of
finding kind of the one type of content
that you like the most
now I still want to maintain a
probability distribution I'm not worried
about sharing it on one type of content
I'm happy with the probability
distribution of a content and the
constraint here is that we have to
satisfy we have to balance the
probability mass across groups and
within that we still optimize so we
still want to get the most reward we
still want you to like it as much as
possible but we have to maintain that
balance so again you have to kind of
change the notion of regret a little bit
because now we're thinking about this
kind of a fair optimal solution that we
compare against but the goal is still
just to learn what that is and again we
want to do this of course with a very
fast and low regret algorithms to do
this so so what we can do here
let's again just tweak the algorithm a
little bit so before again we had that
kind of best arm that we were selecting
with a high probability mass now instead
of doing that with a high probability
mass we select from the empirical
optimal based on what we've seen so far
right so we have some kind of cue hat
which is what we think is optimum based
on what we've seen with high probability
we select from that and with a small
boundary we still do our exploration and
still test out other things so again
what does this look like this is what it
was before and if you break down by
groups this is the amount of probability
mass we have just added on these
constraints which means that we so which
means that the original solution was not
what we wanted right
so basically these red ones are are over
we put too much mass now on this
particular blue type of content now the
question is what is the right or what is
the right probability distribution and
finding this Q hat is not always easy it
depends on the group structure but in
this case if you have a partition it's
actually very simple and what you can do
is basically just a greedy algorithm
where you look at what is the highest
what is the next highest piece of
content and then you try to put it there
so you just go to the next highest piece
of content and put it there now this
content was blue that wouldn't work for
us right because it'll still be blue so
we'd have to move on to the next person
but we keep doing that until we find
find a distribution that works and you
can prove that this is optimal so indeed
agent showed his uploads as fast as as
we can do it and there's some very some
very nice new fast optimization
techniques even let you do something
very similar when the group's group
structure is much more much more
complicated okay so another to give
another example from online systems is
ranking so everything winds up getting
back so you have a bunch of images you
want to order these and in some kind of
ranking that you're going to display
online
and basically now each image has some
kind of utility that the user gets from
seeing that image in a particular
location okay so the goal generally is
to basically maximize this utility now
again there's many different ways of
defining the utility and many different
algorithms for doing it but largely most
algorithms boil down to this and now the
question is what should this what should
this order be and this also kind of ties
back into the search engine manipulation
effect paper that I mentioned that just
that even if you have the same items
just changing the presentation order it
can change perceptions okay so again
here we have to think of what are the
constraints or constraints make sense in
this and this setting basically what the
constraints mean our ways are just upper
bounds on the number of individuals from
any particular group that can appear in
the top K positions right so if we go
down the list you want to make sure that
for every K there is some maximum amount
for any particular group and I can show
up there so if these are our they are
people across the top and these are
positions of this matrix represents
these utilities these weights of putting
this particular person in a particular
location and here just by the way I've
arranged the numbers it's okay and then
you can have your upper bounds right so
based on how how these numbers work out
if our goal is of course to find find a
ranking that maximizes this overall
utility well the first thing that we
could do is just again try to do this
greedily but if we just try to do that
which corresponds to kind of taking this
diagonal in this matrix we soon run into
a problem right where we where we
violate this constraint as we start our
fine and has the first two this one blue
person there's two blue people
two blue people and one yellow person
but now we've and this fourth position
we run into a problem we don't want more
than two of any particular group and we
have three blue people so what do we
have to do we have to do something a
little bit
but what we can do is actually very
simple again there's a very simple
greedy algorithm that works we just try
to work our way down this day I don't
know and as soon as there's a problem
right as soon as the next person that we
would add in will create a violation in
these constraints we just keep working
our way down the line until we find
someone who does not violate the
constraints and then we try to go back
to this diagonal and keep working our
way down so this is another example
where again it's something very simple
it's a very simple greedy algorithm and
the reason why this works is really
because these constraints we have as I
said they're they're so nice right if
you look at if you look at arbitrary
constraints in this problem you could
say okay from position one and five and
seven I want this in position three and
for another or not we want that but that
doesn't make sense in the finest context
what the type of constraints that make
sense here are really amenable to this
kind of very nice fast greedy algorithms
okay so those are just two examples but
we've been looking at a whole a whole
bunch of different ways of thinking
about this problem in different
algorithms and seeing when and how we
can we can basically come up with these
fast solutions so again things like
sampling when you're kind of sub
sampling data or selecting things for
image search personalization which
includes Facebook and Google News
ranking or you you can also look at
hiring or crowd sourcing a fun one we've
been doing lately is voting so actually
in Switzerland they have one of the
Canton's one of the states is rewriting
their constitution so they're trying to
decide which committee should rewrite it
and they want this committee to be
balanced which i think is fantastic
right so they wanted to have
representation from many different
people many different types of people so
they're actually going to use this to as
part of that election process to make
sure that the committee that is selected
is balanced or is fair so the take home
here is really in some sense like how
can you avoid reinventing the wheel if
you look at all of these problems it's
basically a constrained version of some
there already exists you don't have to
come up with a brand new algorithm it's
just some very simple constraints add it
on top of them and often things already
work so often you have kind of a
constrained optimization tool kit that
you can use right away and if that's not
fast enough because those are often
overkill for the simple quest rate that
we have often just a very simple greedy
algorithm won't work so again the key
take home here is just think about these
problems try to not reinvent the wheel
see what you can use that it's already
there this should not be kind of an
overwhelming prospect I think a lot of
companies like to have us think that oh
you know they really wish they could be
fair or they really wish they could be
unbiased but there's all these technical
hurdles I'm not buying it and I don't
think you should either I think that
often there are some many things that we
can do if we have the intention to do it
ok so one thing that you might have
noticed in that example I gave or that
view would quickly come to a few start
thinking about these things is that ok
but if I was trying to optimize
something and now I start putting
constraints on it then my end result is
not going to be as good so this is now
this is really the main objection that
that companies well how that ok how will
this hit the bottom line and because
that's not something that they would
know they would want to happen so here's
just one example for personalization
where we looked at a an existing data
set that had a bunch of articles they
were kind of split up into different
groups in terms of types of content like
sports and entertainment politics and
world politics things like that and we
had explicit data from a variety of
users that were reading these articles
and giving explicit ratings so we're
using this as a kind of underlying
ground truth and we ran some
counterfactual experiments looking at
the different by varying the constraints
and measuring the performance
personalization setting so here the
y-axis is the performance so higher is
better and the x-axis is a constraint
and so on the far left these are no
constraints we case means we don't place
any constraint and on the far right it's
the tightest possible constraints which
means that we force exactly one eighth
of content from each group so that's the
tightest type of constraint you could
have in this setting so what we talked
about before and what our algorithm was
proved the resulting algorithm is that
that regret is small regret is just the
difference between what our algorithm
which is the red line can do as opposed
to the optimal which is before we learn
right if we knew everything ahead of
time what we should do so this this gap
is indeed small as expected and I think
you can't do better than that
but what I'm talking about here is this
gap so what is the gap between the
unconstrained optimal and how much it's
even possible for us to get when we add
these dryness constraints so here
there's a here there's a gap and
actually I chose this particular
experiment in this particular dataset to
show you because out of all the data
that I've looked at and all the
experiments that we looked at in all of
these different platforms this is
actually one where it's the worst in
many cases this gap is inexistent and
really what's happening is that so this
gap can be there in the worst case right
so it could be that there's only one
type of content that you like and you're
like it way more than everything else
and I put constraints so hard on it that
you never get to see that I don't know
ok so this is a worst case example and
this gap is going to be huge in that
case but there is rarely worse case
where as you all know and what ends up
happening is that usually from all
groups for most all groups there will be
some piece of content that you would
still like for the most part right
so what happens is that these
distribution basically these
distribution of data across groups is
not so different we have so much data
there's so much news online there's so
many Facebook story that we could
possibly show you that there will be
something that we can show you that
satisfy the constraints and you like
almost as much right and that's really
that what we see in the morning when we
start digging into this data so that's
that's also something to keep in mind
don't be kind of scared that this is
going to hurt hurt the bottom line often
often it doesn't often we don't even see
any any gap here now from the
theoretical point of view because I was
at least initially a few edition of
course you would also want some formal
guarantees on this price of fairness
there's something else that we've been
working on and some for some problems we
have it in some problems we don't but
basically the question is what
properties of the data can we measure
that would then guarantee that we have a
small price of fairness and this is
again something we've been working on
for some problems we can actually even
prove to you that this gap is going to
be negligible for the data that you have
okay so I just want to kind of pivot a
little bit to look at some some other
experiments in related to or to relate
to these type of metrics or relate to
how we're measuring this bottom line so
this is one study we conducted a few
years ago or looking at MOOCs massive
open online courses and we had two books
we were looking at one was intro to art
and intro to CS and we were looking at
different ways of again ranking content
in this case in the forms so a little
bunch of forums where people could post
a question hi this is some question and
then there were answers so people would
answer the multiple-choice question and
write a little gloom about it - in many
forms here they're also of votes that
were being displayed and our original
question we wanted to understand how
with different mechanisms for basically
collecting information from users as to
how to rank rank data so as a as kind of
our ideal benchmark initially we looked
at kind of a curated ranking so this is
a professor explicitly went through and
ranked these ranked these answers we had
a social condition which is this one
that you see here where people can vote
and then we also show you how many votes
each a chancer had we had a non social
condition where people can sell up vote
but basically these green boxes weren't
there so you couldn't see the numbers of
how many people had a boat at each one
and of course we had this kind of random
baseline or we just ordered things don't
normally so so what did we learn here so
the first thing that we looked at we had
some independent experts quit each
answer and then we looked at the top of
the ranking here I'm showing you for the
top three and we said okay what is the
average grade and that these top answers
had for these four different types of
rankings so perhaps unsurprisingly in
both courses if you look at the curated
rate the ones that the professor order
that had the highest I had the highest
grade if you're familiar with this area
it's also not surprising that the non
social condition had the second highest
grade because as soon as you have social
and things you can have herding and
things like that and sometimes you end
up with some sub optimal solutions
followed by social and of course random
was lost so this is all a suspect was a
suspect but then we thought about okay
well what if we kind of measure how good
these rankings are a little bit
differently instead of looking at these
experts we looked at the students
themselves and we looked at their
performance and the quiz at the end of
the week all right so how well are they
performing and their quiz when they were
exposed to these various conditions and
here completely switched around we were
actually quite surprised to see that the
social condition was actually the best
in both cases and perhaps a little bit
embracing ly the random condition was
quite good in the art course even better
than what the professor's had done so of
course the first thing we did was check
everything and no there was no bug and
sit down and think okay well how is it
possible why is random doing so well
here what what changed and what we
realized is that basically even though
kind of objectively if you look at these
answers individually they're on average
lowering quality they're also much more
diverse so the type of answers are the
social condition was surfacing were
quite different from each other right
right so if you look at which answer is
a professor thought was best they were
largely very similar right so what the
point here is that what we were missing
in this first metric that's all we're
not really looking at kind of the
collective information that was given
and that was being given by by the top
of a list and if you look at the
collective information then diversity is
of course a very good thing to have all
right it doesn't it's not useful to read
the same answer rephrase the different
way what's useful is to hear a different
point or maybe an answer that's not as
complete but raises something new and
this is and this is what we what we see
evidence in the second metric this so
the same way that what is fairness what
is diversity
there's again different ways of looking
at it but basically you can think of
different groups of answers you have
different types of answers this is a
real question from Cora I think how many
eggs are in it doesn't okay if you look
at the kind of quality based ranking you
might end up again with kind of the same
information at the top if we look at a
diverse ranking the idea is that you
have different types of information and
you kind of see a little bit of
everything near the top so this was
another study we did on very Stock
Exchange sites where we looked at I know
the maximally the ranking that has the
most amount of diversity and by
and looking at these different basically
we took all the answers they were
classified into different groups and the
maximally diverse ranking would just
kind of round-robin across choosing one
answer from every group within a type it
would sort by quality and we compared
and a Stack Overflow ranking which was
already being done by upwards so was
already more diverse than the kind of
this quality only ranking but not as
diverse as our diverse ranking and here
we conducted a bunch of experiments on
Amazon Mechanical Turk asking the users
okay which of these rankings do you
prefer and again what we saw was largely
the users for the very different stock
exchanges still preferred our diverse
ranging now here we optimize anything is
maximally diverse is probably or is
perhaps too diverse I don't know we have
to go back and look at this a little bit
more but generally them what we saw is
that this adding more diversity even
more than what the votes were already
getting was a positive thing resulted in
more positive user experience so again
if you just look at the quality as
measured by again either by outside
experts that the quality is measured by
the number of votes at the top of the
list this is decreasing your quality but
overall it is improving user
satisfaction so these these three things
really lead me to this question of are
you using the right metrics I suppose oh
okay this gap now could be there
generally we don't even tell you see it
we have to think a little bit about what
are the right what are the metrics that
were using and the end of whenever we're
designing these applications what we
want is largely to increase user
satisfaction right that's what will keep
people coming back that's what we want
to do on on some level and there are
some I guess a fairly standard ways of
doing it really standard metrics of
measuring this but that's still just an
approximation and I find that largely
these approximations are also designed
with some constraints now there should
be kind of relatively fast and
relatively easy to compute and
because we need them to be fast and easy
to compute they tend to break down the
into these individual components looking
at each answer individually finding a
grade and taking an average rate that's
easy if you have to measure how good
something is collectively with every
group as you add each and each a piece
of content then things can become more
complicated although there are there are
more and more metrics that are doing
this so are using the right metrics do
they capture diversity and how much does
diversity impact impact the quality of
the result how much the users like your
results and how much they're coming back
okay okay so I think there's still I
think there's still a lot a lot to do
here
we've talked a little bit about some of
the problems that that we've seen the
areas where we seen problems and some of
the algorithms that we've developed but
this is still kind of a just one piece
of the larger puzzle I think there's a
lot of things that I kind of brushed
under the rug in order to be able to get
to tell you about some of them two
things we've been doing but I think
there's a lot of really cool interesting
problems that I hope some of you can can
help us tackle I think one of the key
questions is how can we automate these
processes
all right so how can we detect bias in
an automated way we can't count on
waiting for a journalist's to go find
some problem in some algorithm that's
being used for the public making a big
fuss about it and getting it all over
the news and then a couple of computer
science starts setting it's it's not an
efficient way of doing things so how can
we actually go find ways to build this
automatic detection into our oven and
where we start measuring the behavior of
the algorithm as it is running as it is
learning as it is changing I think
another very difficult is how to define
the groups so what are the groups that
we want to be fair across if you're
talking about something like this parole
case and then that is a little bit more
well defined
as a society we are government we have
kind of agreed upon certain attributes
of people that were not allowed to
discriminate it yes so our algorithm
should not discriminate according to
those features that one is a little bit
more straightforward but in this online
space it's no longer clear right when I
show this this example of images should
be just care about gender should we care
about ethnicity how do we even tell from
an image sometimes so trying to find
trying to understand what are these
what are these group that we should be
fair across and also finding ways to
efficiently learn the the group
membership properties of content is
another kind of very important open
question which which I don't have a good
answer to of course there's a lot of
more work to do around algorithmic
solutions things like what what I talked
about today there are so many other
problems for applications where where we
can try to apply this framework to yeah
I'm just one person we have a small team
so it is what if we can but the more the
more than I am definitely happy to talk
to anybody if we have some particular
problem in mind and there was also this
other kind of largely open question
which I pointed out about proving formal
guarantees so when can we actually one
can actually show that and this price of
fairness is small and when we and even
if we catch us well what are the right
metrics to use here how can we define
that the metrics that really captured is
more holistic approach to studying
equality for algorithms output now the
and another point that I think is it's
difficult to supporting this deployed so
as I mentioned we've been talking to a
bunch of policy makers I'm in
Switzerland so it's nice to be close to
Geneva so there's a lot of
interest from the UN and all these other
regulatory agencies basically thinking
about okay what even makes sense like
does it make sense to regulate
algorithms what would it mean to
regulate algorithms with respect to
fairness of course there's already the
GD P R which is doing all kinds of
perhaps positive perhaps some negative
as well things related to to privacy on
a global level so what would that look
like for fairness and I think it is so
crucial that technologists actually talk
to regulatory agencies otherwise it will
end up being pretty meaningless and
anything that and that I won't come up
with so I really enjoyed you also to
just go out and talk to as many non CSV
people as you can because it also gives
you a very interesting very different
perspective sometimes we do end up in
our bubble I've definitely been guilty
of this where we're kind of in the
trenches of kind of digging through some
data or trying to come up with some
technical solution beyond saying okay
what even makes sense as for as a
definition of fairness what even makes
sense is something that is even possible
to regulate and of course the last thing
is studying the impact so we're still
kind of on the in the early stages of
these and I'm at a university so we have
a few kind of little small demos for a
bunch of this work that we've done but
it would be really great to see this
actually being used in companies
actually being used on real users
actually looking at that data and seeing
what difference it makes is this
bringing users back how do they interact
with the system differently what are
kind of the long-term effects on their
behavior on their opinions and things
like that so thanks I think I can is
right on time it was great getting to
talk to you guys and I'm really happy
that we'll have a Q&A session so please
do come I'd love to hear your
perspective and get a chance to talk a
bit more
[Applause]
I I thought maybe to take one question
here so to kind of start kicking off the
discussion so you are asking yesterday
thanks sir apparently handing in arts
expert a bunch of random posts about an
image doesn't really change the quality
as gauged by experts whereas in computer
science it does very strongly did I
didn't understand the image you showed
about the ratings and ratings by other
experts so that in the arts field like
handing a set of experts so the top of
picture handing a set of experts some
random posts and letting them sort them
in a certain way doesn't really change
the quality of the overall set of the
text whereas in computer science
it does change the perceived quality a
lot so I compared the purple bars versus
the red bars so my question is are there
certain fields in the news or something
where there might be latent fear that
being fair might reduce the quality of
the news a lot whereas in others
apparently it doesn't really affect it
if you say that the random bar is kind
of fair or diverse versus the curated is
very much focusing on a certain group
yeah so here the difference was so here
is pointing out the difference between
the art and the computer science that in
one they were kind of the same whereas
another there's there's a gap here I
think here so in this particular study
what what we saw is that basically this
computer science course was harder and
there are many answers that were just
flat-out incorrect so if you randomized
and put in correct answers at the top
then that's going to affect your quiz
scores whereas for art most the answers
were mostly correct so that's why there
was a gap here so that's definitely
something that would be in this case
course dependent I think your your
broader question is very
interesting that is it do we have to
think about in some in some sense based
on the on the field when it makes sense
to be more diverse or not and what you
proposed so basically if kind of random
is already diverse then maybe it's okay
to diversify yeah that's a that's an
interesting way of looking at it I think
one thing that this framework lets you
do is that what you can do is basically
place constraints so that you push
everything towards fairness by an
epsilon amount so that might be one way
to to do this so that okay everything
becomes a little bit more fair but it's
not too far from what you were doing
anyways so that's possibly one way to do
it if that's that's what you would like
to try okay thanks thanks